[Music]
hey guys we're starting a new series
called
analyzing the original this is where i
look at content that i put out in the
world and i try to add more context
this could be a really fruitful series
so we're gonna try it out we're trying
to innovate you've seen over
under we're gonna try to do this and uh
and let's get into the first episode you
could have ended up being a bus
a tree i just don't get the mentality of
being head down
sad on a monday morning ah the classic
so what went through your head on
february 22nd
2015 and you thought you had to make
this video
were we doing dailyvee
why were you there did i text you in the
morning and say on
saturday night before you got hyped i
now remember i was reading
i mean almost everything that i come up
with comes from reading and listening i
always talk about
you hear me talking you hear me
interrupting people on [ __ ] the reason i
interrupt i think
in podcasts is i've already heard what
the person's gonna say and i do a bad
job
like really think about the audience
because i'm in the moment and i'm not a
great interviewer for that reason but
i am listening and i was reading
comments drock
and was like man people [ __ ] hate
monday
and i was like we need to change the
perspective on this like people really
depressed anxious
upset angry and they're alive and they
can do something about it
so first let's put things into
perspective and i really just
right i text you as i come over monday
morning we're going to film this [ __ ]
i'm glad that it was like a gloomy day
and i'm glad it like turned out to be
like this this is a real classic
what made this video so so successful do
you think a couple things happen i think
it caught a lot of people's truth
which is in general what i think my
content does i think the setting was
very raw and real
i mean this is now drock we're getting
old this is six
years ago this did really well on on
instagram
on facebook it was just raw it was super
real i really meant it
i feel like i'm always at my best when i
mean it remember how you ended the video
no remember you aren't in the video i
can like almost
feel the start but i don't necessarily
remember
cool uh wait wait i was gonna have you
how to recreate it before you listen to
it
you could have been hit by a [ __ ] bus
i remembered a bus coming by
you could have been bored a tree or you
could be born a bus you could have ended
up being a bus
a tree so it's early monday morning
and i've been wanting to make a monday
morning video for a long time and
finally drock we're doing it so
real quick stop right there a couple
weeks ago i wrote a blog post about
smoke than fire i'm always smoking i'm
always smoking so clearly what happened
in that weekend was
i read enough dms or emails that finally
got me over the top
that my smoke became fire which was
me saying that to the audience is like
this has been on my mind and it has
people hating monday is something i've
really been in tune with because i hated
monday
from 1982 to 1998 because i hated school
this is just a rant very simple and
something that i want you to pass on or
watch every monday morning
because the level of complaining is
unacceptable look
what if i told you this was the last
monday morning of yours right
what if i told you you died this week
would you complain about your crap job
think about that i was today i was with
a guy for 15 minutes
who's working with the sasha group and
he talked about oh he's hearing me about
this so he's resonated and then his son
had a brain tumor and he was going so
hard all these businesses and he's like
who gives a [ __ ] i was like yeah and
like people need to
know that like people are complaining
right now about
pay about burnout about covid
not going skiing and like cool i get it
and it's
there's nothing wrong with being
disappointed
but [ __ ] being dwelling and
devastated and like
life is ruined when there's so much
pain in the world around people who've
really lost loved ones or
died or really really affected by this
disease you got to put things in
perspective
and i really do believe that people
would not hate their monday and complain
about their job
if they knew that it was their last
monday they just wouldn't think about
the world that way and
think living that way while being
patient it's that friction of the
opposite opinions like live like it's
your
last day on earth but like anticipate
living for 50 years it's a tough
juxtaposition for people to handle
opposite thinking and i think that's
what really works for me
or that test you don't want to take i
doubt it you would go much
higher level thinking well that's really
what it takes
it takes understanding that if you're
not pumped right
now if you're begrudging what you're
about to do if you're you're not looking
forward to it look
i respect practicality you got to go
through school because your parents want
to do don't be grudged
pay your rent you got student loans i
get it but please recognize by the way
that's just a moment of less if we're
doing the analyst like
who gives a [ __ ] that i didn't say a
word you got the point
people like stop because they're like oh
i lisped a little bit on like that word
i don't give a [ __ ] just penetrate
through like
people will connect with your
authenticity not if you
pronounce a word properly anybody that
gets caught up on [ __ ]
pronunciation and grammar is playing the
[ __ ] small game anyway
why do people get caught because they're
[ __ ] micro
fear-based they need to control little
things to make them feel
comfortable like because they're
nitpicking because they're trying to
tear down the person that's making the
content because they wish they were
um because they grew up in a proper
framework
where it was unacceptable but like but
there's
so much deep unhappiness playing in that
framework there's nobody
ecstatic and glowing that they
lived life properly around pronunciation
or grammar i promise this internet thing
created
way more opportunity for all of us way
more
i mean look when you know the world's
abundant you can get happy
could have had sex like three minutes
later and you wouldn't even exist
and you're complaining you could have
ended up being a bus who wants to be a
bus
i just don't get the mentality of being
head down
sad on a monday morning it's not
practical monday morning my [ __ ]
i'm gonna have a little saturday monday
morning that's what i want to do
tomorrow
morning and that's what i want from you
please take a step back
and think about how awesome it actually
is and then
recognize that you can attack the world
in a totally different way
because you were life to be born during
this
life is how you see it
yeah honestly like monday the brand like
pisses me off the way
other things like branding of things
that are like
huh you know friday thank god it's
friday hump day it's like a whole
systematic machine to accept being
unhappy in your job
like it's just it's not a good idea
and and i think life is how you see it
and if you think
it's supposed to be a life of like not
liking your job you just got to get
through it put on your hat like
things that you have to do keeping it
real
keeping it real negative a lot of people
keep it real negative i want to keep it
real real real positive there's always
opportunity
if you take on accountability patience
practicality focus
like you can make it better because
millions
and tens of millions and hundreds of
millions of people have made their lives
better
over the last 30 years so why can't you
that's real talk
that i'm really glad i said because
that's [ __ ] truth
if tens of millions of people over the
last 25 years
have figured out a way to make their
life better why can't you
look i'm a feedback machine as you heard
please leave a comment
if i've ever brought you value please
leave a comment right now so i can get a
sense of where this is going what did
you like about this what stood out
what should we be thinking about this
community of ours
is a togetherness thing i need your
feedback
set your alerts triple digits on
instagram
bells and whistles on youtube set your
alerts i need your feedback i need your
feedback because i want to make it
better i want to make it better for you
please leave your comments on this new
series youtube watcher what's up it's
garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon